Jen Morrison
she had a very emotional reaction she
said man this is embarrassing so I said
I'm not embarrassed one bit try harder
next time I wasn't embarrassed to say
what I had said it's true you all know
it's true I don't care if you hate
Andrew Tate let me ask you a question
[ __ ] goes down in your neighborhood
you're gonna call and you have two
options right there's crime happening
all over you got to get to the corner
there's [ __ ] that's gone down you act
like that can't happen did you ever you
ever remember the the videos of cities
on fire Portland and everything remember
on CNN when the guy was like that's
peaceful here and the whole city was Up
in Flames behind him I mean the dumb and
just the it's just like
you're gonna let me ask you you're gonna
and you have two options you can call
Andrew Tate world champion kickboxer or
you can call Jedediah you're gonna call
me I show up hi
five four and a half fit but like you
have your choice so you're gonna come on
don't be dishonest with yourself you
know you're gonna call a guy like that
who do you have in the military people
who do you have in the military a bunch
of [ __ ] no that's right I said the
word who do you have in the military
you want you want guys who do you want
to show up when there's a fire you want
a big ass man to show up he's gonna
carry you up all those flights of stairs
you know it come on you don't have to be
it's like saying like if we were walking
down a dark alley and it's you know
we're in a small group at valuetainment
do people feel safer walking with me or
Patrick David Patrick is like if you if
you put two of me on like you stood me
up and then you put another one of me on
top of me maybe I'd be Patrick's height
so you just gotta be realistic people
these people are just living in some
type of weird woke bubble where they
can't even admit fact anymore because
they're just too they're trembling to
hate them they're trembling to hate him
all right Jen Morrison
so I look I see who she is Jen went on
and on by the way this went on for a
while I look and I see freelance writer
New York Times the Atlantic Washington
Post Self Magazine
chiher
the pronouns freelance you know what
that means that means she doesn't have a
job
it means nobody likes her enough to hire
her
Tyler woke up on the wrong side of the
bed today so you don't want it let me
tell you his commentary is gonna be good
this kind of Tyler this is what we
signed up for what does that mean no
freelance it means nobody here likes her
enough to keep her full time your
personality sucks enough for the times
that they won't keep you full-time there
you go well it's all woke Publications
so that Parents Magazine I don't know I
don't read that Huffington Post we know
what that is okay so she her so she had
emotional reaction whatever
so I wrote
she writes me again if you're not
embarrassed to defend a man currently
facing sex trafficking and rape charges
that's on you hard to comprehend
particularly from a mother where are the
charges
where are the charges
where are the rape charges I ask
I I couldn't find charges I certainly
know he had first of all I didn't I
didn't have the heart to tell her that
charges is not the same as finding
something right you can charge somebody
like you can accuse somebody it's not
the same as being found guilty there's a
distinction that needs to be made there
with anybody this isn't just about Tate
right because you had charges again I'm
going to bring it up against Brett
Kavanaugh you had somebody coming up say
oh he's sexually she didn't have any
evidence in fact the people that she
brought forward to say they're going to
corroborate my story they were like oh
honey actually that's not what happened
so
has this guy been found guilty so I
write he has not been charged a
convicted of sex trafficking a rape if
that change is all plenty to say about
it I don't agree with Tate or anyone
else on everything but I've defended his
right to voice his own opinion
I'm not seeing charges of rape I don't
see it I do not see it I looked I
researched I tried to find it in fact
let me say this about Tate
I don't know what's going to come up on
this guy I don't know him personally
I'm just here to tell you what I see and
what's you know what I like about what
he says but I don't like I don't know
but if this guy this guy is the target
of everybody all the people the media
they can't stand it like or if this guy
had charges out somebody had come
forward and said he raped me whether
that was true or not that would be front
headline everywhere I'm not seeing it
I'm not seeing it so I don't I don't
know man I I don't I don't know
so I wrote
um
here's the next exchange she writes yes
Free Speech but that's not what you
tweet that's not what your Tweet was
about you implied he would be the hero
we all need instead of men you consider
to be lesser than which is a Pity I
never said he was a hero so I wrote
Never implied anyone is a hero I have
one hero and it's God that's the truth
what I said is that if dangerous should
hit the fan physically strong
unapologetically masculine men who know
how to fight and have zero interest in
woke slogans are exactly who we'd call
and that remains my opinion is it not
true I invite you in the chat by the way
hit your subscribe button hit your like
button if you like seeing me take on
this wolf psychosis because we could do
more of this
is it not true
is it not true that you if [ __ ] at the
fan you wouldn't want somebody like him
who's just got no time for [ __ ] it's
not going to be about oh I mean should
we have somebody outside that's like
well I don't know if I want to go in
because I'm feeling a certain type of
way today no no you don't
do you don't you don't want somebody
who's gonna you want somebody just gonna
react right unapologetically masculine
means that they're not afraid of the
things that make them a strong-ass man
that's what you want in situations that
are dangerous
interestingly enough I extended to Jen
and invitations come on the show she had
been going back and forth with me for a
while I said you have an open invite to
come on my show to discuss if you're
interested I'm happy to have you on I
stand by my Twitter comment but happy to
discuss that length of the long
performance suddenly there was silence
how shocking how surprising and I I that
imitation holds if you're a feminist out
there by the way put it in the chat
please if you're a feminist and you
don't like what I'm saying you want to
come on and have this debate with me
let's do it let's do it because I am
debating this Co from from a position of
fact and what we know and information we
have and the fact that it's very obvious
to me very obviously there was a
campaign to shut down a guy that a lot
of people felt his message was
destructive
and I did all research I looked at it so
I laid it out here because you know why
people say why do you do this on Twitter
Jed I do it because you gotta like stop
this nonsense you gotta gut out the
cancer of actual misinformation before
you get labeled misinformation even
though you're telling the truth and
suddenly you're bent you can't you got
to cut the cancer out and the cancer is
this willingness of people who are very
fragile
to label people your bigot you're a
misogynist rapist racist raping they
don't know what word to say with no
justification because essentially what
it is is they're uncomfortable with his
commentary they don't like it and
they're like shaken because they don't
know what to do about it if you want to
watch the full episode click right here
and if you want to ask me a question
talk one-on-one send me a FaceTime video
join a video with a group of your
friends and me you gotta download manect
and you gotta join me there it's gonna
be really hot
[Music]